um so we're going to talk about
um targets yeah Bud Light the e-i-c-e-i
ESG PRI and companies
so please educate us yeah okay so so a
couple things you guys hear about what
uh the Oscars Academy just announced
three weeks ago and what it takes to be
nominated for an Oscar moving forward
have you guys heard about this or no no
so Hollywood just came out and announced
that moving forward to be nominated for
an Academy you have to have your leading
role on any movie a percentage of it has
to be from a underrepresented community
the actors have to be part of a
underrepresented community the workers
behind camera have to be part of a third
has to be part of a underrepresented
community a uh the editors the shredders
the camera guys a third have to be part
of underrepresented communities you can
Google this and show it or else you
cannot be nominated meaning wow and then
they broke down what it means to be part
of the underrepresented Community if you
want to know what those six things are
to be part of the underrepresented
community here's how they Define it to
be part of the underrepresented
community okay number one is
people like women people of color lgbtq
plus people with disabilities people
from low-income communities people from
rural areas and people of indigenous
Heritage what if you are that and you
have a third of it in some of the
categories then you can be nominated for
a Oscar let me explain to who does not
qualify If This Were to ever happen and
pretty much 99 of movies that everyone
in Oscar would not be able to qualify
today to do this here's a part that
people don't really realize that's going
on in Hollywood you guys know why all
the creative actors escaped to go to
Hollywood like you do you know where
they escaped from to end up going to
Hollywood Jersey why Jersey Hollywood
used to be in Jersey why because Thomas
Edison was in Jersey so if you go type
in Thomas Edison New Jersey Hollywood
you'll see the reason why they left
Jersey and Thomas Edison because it was
so regulated that he said you have to
make movies based on my guidelines or
else finally these guys are like screw
this place we're going to Hollywood so
to go to Hollywood in 1920 all the major
Motion Pictures movies that were made 95
of all the major Motion Picture movies
were made in Hollywood you know what
that number is today 55 million four
years ago do you know how many people
watched the Oscars in America 44 million
you know how many people watch the
Oscars this year 18.7 million the three
worst years of watching the Oscars in
the last 20 years were the last three
years people are done today I want to
watch the movie with Sebastian
Maniscalco and uh Robert De Niro it's a
new movie about a father all this other
stuff right off the bat the movie starts
with an lgbtq Community if you watch the
new uh uh what is the new uh Fast and
Furious the guy that's uh what is the
Aquaman what's the guy
he's gay
he's gay in the morning Fast and the
Furious is gay so guess what so now
people have to say I don't send this
stuff why are they doing this Bud Light
loses 25 anheus approaches it's 25 of
sales since they decided to team up with
Dylan Mulvaney Target since they
announced they have a transection
because of pride month their stock
dropped 12 they lost 9 billion dollars
Target get lost 9 billion dollars in a
span of roughly two weeks damn their
stock drop why
so people say well these CEOs are idiots
they're morons you should do this they
have no clue what they're doing you
should fire this person that's not how
this thing works so the whole thing you
have to look at how this thing comes
about so un United Nations comes out
with something called PRI then PRI
starts raising money from ngos ngos are
non-governmental organizations so such
as Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation you
know all these other companies that have
given a motion right you got it yes
so then these ngos come out with this
ESG score and the ESG score they have a
couple different areas one is called Dei
diversity Equity inclusive and then they
have the CEI I think it's called
corporate Equity index or something like
that then there's an organization called
HRC human rights committee that is
funded by open Society Foundation open
Society Foundation has been given 32
billion dollars of money by one guy
named George Soros you know George Soros
uh open Society Foundation one of those
George sources Foundation since 1984
George Soros has given open Society
Foundation 32 billion dollars of his own
money not other people's money his own
money so what does this have to do with
anything
this thing as you get deeper it's even
crazier do you know BlackRock I don't
know if you've heard of BlackRock Larry
Fink you know Vanguard and you know
State Street do you know how much money
BlackRock has under management do you
know the number of how much assets under
management BlackRock has if you were to
take a wild guess how much assets under
management blackrockcast what would you
say that number is I'll say this they're
buying up like all the single-family
homes the United States right now you're
a smart guy you're a sharp guy what
would you say that number is how much
you think they have assets under
management AUM assets under management
what do you think it is can I give a
percentage of how many of what what how
much assets they have can I give
percentage I don't know the exact amount
what dollar man you think would be a lot
of money I'm again I'll put it to you
this way have you heard of Guggenheim
that bought the Dodgers they have 300
billion dollars of assets under
management oak tree Capital Management
that gave us we worked with them before
they have 160 billion dollars under
management Bain Capital massive they
have 100 billion dollars of assets under
management what do you think BlackRock
has assets under management I'm going to
say between five to six hundred billion
then you ready 11 trillion dollars wow
did you hear what I just said 11
trillion by the way ten and a half
eleven trillion now do you know what the
US GDP was last year 32 trillion yeah
okay so America as a business did 32
trillion last year Black Rock has 11
trillion dollars BlackRock Vanguard and
State Street combined have roughly uh a
10 stake to 15 stake on 88 of s p 500
companies let me say that one more time
wow BlackRock Vanguard State Street
collectively have roughly 10 to 15
percent of equity in nearly 88 of s p
500 companies that's [__] crazy and
200 companies in the United States top
500 companies
24.9 of board seats are controlled by
BlackRock van guard and State Street
nearly 88 percent of these guys so what
does this mean guess what they do they
control everything yeah they control
everything so they get to tell the
companies if you want to borrow money
from me for example let's just say your
name is Dodgers you're like man if we
want to really give this guy a contract
for 400 million dollars over 10 years
let's go raise the money all right hey
can you give us some money here no
problem BlackRock here's 100 million
Banker Mark here's 100 million Goldman
Sachs here's 200 million go off for this
guy 400 million dollar contract but your
ESG score is low what I need you to do
is I need you at the Dodgers game to
have a a lesbian non-indulgence I don't
know if you guys saw the story or not
have you guys seen this thing what
happened at Dodger Stadium I haven't
seen it okay anyway so this whole story
comes out with uh uh uh non there's an
organization called something of
indulgence where transgender women are
out men are out there and doing what
they're doing because Dodgers has to
increase their ESG score these are
people that probably reading books to
kids and all this other stuff
the point with these guys the money guys
are impo imposing High ESG score I'll
give you this final thoughts for you
guys to be thinking about how deep this
is getting you know what the top five
five highest ESG scores in America is
number five is Bank of America number
four Salesforce number three is
Microsoft number two is Intel and number
one is alphabet you know what are some
of the companies with the worst ESG
scores in America Tesla one the worst
yeah Tesla's fixing the environment
helping the environment to have one of
the worst Twitter is one of them yep you
got Xerox as one of them at T is one of
them I can give you fox uh uh uh
corporators one of them these companies
who have low ESG scores they're not
controlled by those guys but those guys
don't give them a good score so they
have a hard time raising more money from
other people it's a it's a mess of what
they're doing say that again do you know
what yes she stands for I was gonna yeah
environmental social governance
environmental social governance I
believe so like basically your how how
woke you are because you are exactly so
it's funny because now there's a social
credit score that they do in China this
is your corporate environmental service
environmental social governance I want
to say so it's funny you don't take over
or destroy infrastructure from outside
beautiful from the inside and control
happens when people have to follow
either regiment or for example a system
and the EFG score is basically our
literal credit score so for companies
like you said before to borrow money you
need to have to score A1 if you don't
you can't borrow money so they can
squeeze them say hey you know what do
these things if you don't do it you
can't borrow money so they have to do it
so but like had to on some level to stay
relevant or stay in the I want to say um
Marketplace itself do these things to
actually be a competitor and borrow
money as well so you think they probably
sold their sold borrowed money and
that's why they had to do that stupid
ass ad this is why Gillette did the
controversial toxic masculinity ad
because I've always been wondering like
why are they taking crazy risks and
ostracizing is there a consumer base so
you don't do it but you know what
happens if you don't do it they control
the board seats if you don't do it guess
what the board is doing to you they're
firing you right how many people you
think want a job paying you 25 million
your salary how many people you think
would like to be the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch how many people you think
would want to be a CEO of Target how
many people you think want that job a
thousand people yeah are you kidding me
guys that went to Harvard Yale you know
Princeton of course there's a thousand
guys that want that job how many people
think are willing to do all of those
things for 25 million year salary plenty
of people Everyone yeah plenty of people
wait Black Rock I was gonna say 10
trillion because they literally buy
every single thing even close to
buildings as well and single family yeah
which means they're going to control
pretty much all of our their first
question why we have a housing shortage
so to speak on purpose yeah it's but
once again what is it all control every
control all you do behind the scenes I
really control company even though
you're the face of it I control the
behind the scenes so so you know now
somebody says somebody says something
like well how do you fight these guys
man how the hell do you fight these guys
okay that's my question exactly because
yeah I in my possible simple mindset I
can't imagine
how you can fight that do you know why
we're even able to have this
conversation right now together for
speech do you know why we're able to
have this conversation right now okay a
Jewish man a middle eastern man a black
man and
okay watch four of us how different we
are and we're sitting at a table right
now and 98 35 is right now watching live
do you know why we're able to do this
right now because we're [__] no
because because of because of probably I
will say a thousand anti-establishment
people in the last 207 years in America
that's why and those thousand
anti-establishment guys
fought for you and I and they've never
met you you'll never meet them you don't
even know what they went through you
don't know how they targeted their
families all this other stuff you and I
are able to have this conversation
because the world still has few
anti-establishment guys that can't be
bought and can be bullied
[Music]
power or not afraid to
wait do you know what is the ultimate
riskiest job in the world
you know it's the riskiest job in the
world
position what is the riskiest position
in the world
uh break a question it's not a president
politician anybody that's loud vocal
fighting against the establishment it's
the riskiest job in the world of course
they'll cancel you period we've seen it
yeah Andrew Tate yeah
Andrew Tate Ryan Dawson you know like if
you talk about anything that challenges
The Establishment and you have a big
enough platform or you talk about talk
about certain taboo subjects they're
going to cancel you
so yeah okay so question though how do
we fight it
so you get to pick and choose like for
example beer companies uh if a person's
sitting there saying I don't like what
the Bud Light is doing no problem guess
what start a beer company whoever starts
to support him on let them get bigger
Ben Miller commercial recently with the
females sure and let them do it yeah but
then if other people start a direct
competitor to them support them whatever
maybe go buy their product go support
their product go do what they're doing
like for example I told Chris today I
said I don't know Chris from Rumble I
said yeah I'm one of your biggest
cheerleaders you don't even know it I
said you have no idea how important it
is what you're doing Rumble is a very
very important to the marketplace very
because there is an alternative place to
go Spotify is very important to the
marketplace there's an alternative place
to go Twitter is a very important place
to the marketplace exactly there's a
place to go these are things that they
have a place to go right for them to go
and we need to support those companies
we need to help out those companies I
agree and we need to build up those
companies it's a uh the solution to some
like this is is
unequivocal up it's a hundred percent of
individuals willing to compete to say I
believe I can do it better okay the fear
you know how a lot of people are like
well you know Patrick it's easy for you
to move your family and go out to
Florida you know you can move your
family go to Florida dude I've moved
since Jennifer and I've been married 13
times
each time we've moved Jennifer's been
pregnant that we moved to a new state
when we moved to Texas she was pregnant
when we moved to Florida she was
pregnant okay we've had four kids born
in three different states we've moved
our office 12 times we moved our house
13 times okay we move people say how
could you really move and go to a
different place listen California for
the first time since 1851 lost people in
the state of California never happened
in the history of California people have
you know why they're sick of it they're
going to a different place so why can't
they go to a different place because of
competition where people live in
California to Texas Florida Arizona
Nevada there is other options people
that are leaving New York where they're
going to Tennessee Florida there's
options people that are leaving Chicago
where they're going to there is options
as long as we can compete the customer
wins the moment you and I cannot compete
we lose so we have to support the
competitors as much as possible who have
the other for example who's daily wire
competing against whether you like daily
wire or not who does daily wire compete
against
um I guess now Rumble let's say you
think so okay let's just say it's Rumble
uh but to me I I put daily wire out
there I put Rumble out there I put
Twitter out there I put any of these
guys out there anybody that's competing
with the traditional media space if they
got a 20 a month product forty dollar a
month product guess what go support them
buy them because if you don't then
you're also supporting the other side
right you know how many people paid a a
Netflix every month you know what the
numbers you know how many active users
they have today do you know the number
probably a Lot 212 million people damn
Netflix 212. Disney's got over 150
million and they have an agenda and they
have an agenda yeah and you know how
many daily wire has two million so
support these guys support the guys that
are willing to do the fight I don't have
a stock in Daily wire I don't have a
stock in uh in in Rumble some people
would even say why are you supporting
your direct competitors because these
guys have the audacity to fight against
the guys that want to control everybody
yes anybody that has the audacity to
support look why I'm here tonight okay I
got four kids my kids were playing
baseball I'm outside playing baseball
with the kids this guy's same path let's
go do this you guys push the envelope I
respect people that push the envelope
it's not an easy job to go out there and
do it I'm driving down here from Fort
Lauderdale to come out here tomorrow I
think you're going to be with us we're
going to touch current events all that
stuff make sure for us to email you the
stuff so you have it tomorrow yeah all
this stuff we're doing why are we doing
it because your challenge status quo
you're pushing the envelope and we need
more people who have the audacity and
willing to put their energy into it and
whoever's doing that support their cause
we need to support more of the Creator's
cause that are willing to fight the
fight they are more important it's very
easy today to you know do what here's
what's easy to do today sit back relax
dude sit back there's so many ways to
make money today yeah what if you just
chill out what if you're like listen man
you know what this freaking [__]
pressure I can't do anything about it
anymore I'm just gonna go relax do my
own thing and live in Singapore and I'm
going to just forget America screw
America America is not doing anything
for me
or you can say no no I'm not going to do
this just I'm not in my D I'm going to
fight great then if those people who
have the audacity to fight we have to
support them damn that's powerful man no
absolutely absolutely uh where are we at
here um man I'm inspired man this is
great so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]